[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
OK, so let's look
at where we are in the class.
So this is the class calendar.
So you can see today is
virtually kind of the midpoint
of the semester.
Now, the other thing
is the reading list.
So today, again, contract
theory and mechanism design.
There's only one
starred reading.
It's "Rentals with
Unobserved Outputs,"
this chapter 5 of Medville.
There is a non-starred
reading, and I have material
on that in the lecture today.
It's this distributed ledger
MIT book, this chapter.
Although I've learned
a little bit more
since I wrote the book, which
was published yesterday,
and I'll share with you a little
bit of that in the lecture.
Anyway, this is all optional.
I'm not quite sure
how many of you
have been following
Bitcoin and so on.
But as I keep saying, every
time an economic topic
comes up that
relates to Bitcoin,
as it did with the
ledgers last time,
then I weave that
into the lecture.
So this is going
to be about today.
The second half of the lecture
is about smart contracts.
And then for the
study guide today, I
can call on a few of
you or get volunteers.
Can someone define for me the
concept of a household balance
sheet, and also, the
income statement?
Just say a few
words about what's
on those financial statements.
Armando, do you want to
take a crack at that?
AUDIENCE: Uh, yeah, sure.
So the balance sheet is where
you keep track of everything
that--
so I'm actually not
sure which is which,
but I know one of
them involves that you
keep track of your assets
and your liabilities.
I believe, yeah, that's
the balance sheet.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The
statement of income
is like all the money in and
as well as all the money that
goes out, expenditures.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
Good.
OK.
Yeah, the balance sheet has
assets on one side, liabilities
on the other.
They don't necessarily balance.
Hopefully, the assets are
greater than the liabilities,
and the difference is equity.
So the liability side
of the balance sheet
also has an equity
component, which
is how much wealth you own that
you do not owe to other people
through debt.
The income statement, you
stated it properly, yes.
You have revenues and expenses.
Now if you take the
difference, you'll
have profits or net
income, and then
a couple of other lines
on that income statement
were how you dispose
of your net income
in terms of either
consuming it or saving it.
But your answer was
great, thank you.
Then we talked about, in
class, life cycle planning.
Can someone tell me
what it is exactly?
What we mean by
life cycle planning?
AUDIENCE: Can I
take a shot at it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: So it's planning
what you're actually,
like what choices you're going
to make over your entire life.
So you're sort of planning
ahead for how much you're
going to spend, like based on
your information about what you
expect your income is going
to be and stuff like that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah.
It's like and now
to, when you die
or when you bequest to
your kids or something.
And typically,
it's year by year.
And it's kind of--
I guess I would say the
point, I didn't ask this,
but the point of
life cycle planning
is to manage your
assets in such a way
that your consumption would
be as smooth as possible
over the years of your life.
And sometimes you can't
achieve that exactly.
The other thing that people
associate with a life cycle
planning is an outcome
of that process,
namely you have a peak where
you're accumulating assets
early on as a young saver with
consumption less than income,
and then you start spending down
those assets when your income
sources diminish,
especially if you retire.
OK.
And then we applied
it to Thailand.
I'm not sure exactly
what to ask about.
Well, maybe if one
of you could tell me
a special feature of the
economic life of Thai villagers
that somehow we incorporated
into the life cycle planner
that you would not
typically see in the US.
AUDIENCE: The gift giving?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: The gift giving
with or without the income.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Excellent.
That's what I was looking for.
Yeah.
So it looks like an individual
operating in isolation,
or at least in most borrowing
or lending and acquiring
financial assets,
but in Thai villages,
those households
interact with one another
by giving gifts and so on.
So the way it was
in the equation
was that it smoothed out
the downfalls in income
because the gifts
would be coming in,
and likewise smoothed
over the peaks
because you give those
peaks away in terms
of gifts to other people.
OK.
Can someone tell me what is
the concept of a distributed
ledger?
AUDIENCE: Is it basically
just like a publicly recorded,
like where you can have
financial transactions be
recorded and available
to other people to see?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So it's a ledger as in
an accounting ledger.
It includes a list
of transactions.
But in addition to that
applying to a given individual,
it's consolidated so that
it includes the transactions
in and out as if it were on a
common ledger, a ledger that
would apply to
all the households
that are participating.
The twist in that is
the word distributed.
So although it's
common, it's not
supposed to be held
by one central party.
Everyone's supposed to have an
identical copy of that ledger.
And in class I
complained a little bit
about when we tried to
create one for the Thai data.
It didn't quite work.
Does someone remember why?
Dixon, you want to
take a stab at it?
AUDIENCE: I'm actually not
really sure why it didn't work.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
That's fine.
Anyone else?
Well, to be fair it
was only on one slide
and there was a lot of material.
So let me highlight.
We didn't have the
distributed ledger running
when I collected the data.
Instead, we took the answers
the households gave us
to the questionnaires and
created financial accounts out
of the answers--
income statement, balance sheet,
and statement of cash flow.
So we had the financial
accounts for all the households,
but we didn't try to reconcile
them to see if they were
consistent with one another.
So in fact, when they
buy something for cash,
they tell us who it was,
potentially in the village.
I buy something from
J, J should show up
with the same transection
where J is selling and getting
cash in return.
So it's one common
transection, it
should show up on a
distributed ledger.
But because the data didn't try
to reconcile all the entries
as they were reported, it was
not unusual for one household
to report a transaction
with another household
that the other household
did not in turn report back.
The point being that distributed
ledgers are an excellent way
of reconciling transactions
live in real time
so that they become
more accurate.
OK.
And then we went to Thailand
and talked about currency,
and there was this--
the whole lecture was about
solving planning problems.
Can someone tell
me in words a bit
about this Miller-Orr
model of cash management?
AUDIENCE: So in the
Miller-Orr model,
the net expenditures are
the sum of smaller recurrent
expenditures and
infrequent larger ones that
have a lower probability.
And so the goal of the household
would be to minimize the cost.
And I remember there was a
Bellman equation for that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's good.
You remember the two
components of the cost?
AUDIENCE: There was the flow
opportunity cost and also
adjustment cost.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, yeah.
So the flow opportunity cost
is the foregone interest
from holding cash.
If you have currency in the
house, it's not in the bank,
it's not earning interest.
So that's kind of the
flow of opportunity cost.
And then every time
you go to a bank,
either deposit or
withdraw the currency,
there is a real
transaction cost.
OK.
So finally, we get
to Kenya and M-Pesa.
Can someone describe for me--
let's see, who's online here--
what exactly is M-Pesa
and how it works?
I'll take a volunteer.
AUDIENCE: I think it's a mobile
phone-based money transfer
service.
And you like, pay a
small fee and then
you can transfer
money to someone else.
It requires trust in
the service, I guess.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: What are they
actually transferring around
electronically?
AUDIENCE: Uh, is it not just
like, I guess like e-money?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's e-money.
It's actually--
AUDIENCE: It's a
telephone, isn't it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It's a cell account.
Yes.
That's right.
It's actually credits.
Like you buy credits for
phone usage in advance
from Safaricom.
So it's just like you would pay
a bill at the end of the month,
they're kind of
like paying a bill
at the beginning of the month.
They're buying
cell phone credits,
but they don't intend to
use it on their cell phone.
Not necessarily.
Instead, they transfer
it around, buy things.
And people cash out, they
reverse the transaction.
So it's like you can--
it's like mileage that
you get on an airplane,
but then you can
sell your miles.
So they can cash out by
selling their e-credit back
to the company.
So in some respects,
it's not so novel.
It's just an electronic
account, in this case,
denominated in terms of
credits on your cell phone.
But what is novel
about it is that it
can be transferred
around at very low cost
and you can cash
in and cash out.
So it kind of looks like
money because you can use it
on your phone like money.
Which then you start to think
about it, what is money really?
It doesn't have to be fiat
money, the paper stuff.
Like you can have
a checking account
in a commercial bank
in the US and pay bills
online out of that account.
It's not central bank
reserves or fiat money,
but it is money in
the sense that it's
used widely in exchange
and has a high velocity.
OK, the trust thing
was a good comment
because we're going
to come to that today
in the lecture in terms
of, in this case, people
trust Safaricom to enter
the transactions properly
and to not cheat after the
fact, not to steal the money,
and to allow them
to cash it out.
But a lot of people
are more paranoid
about third party providers,
depending on the context.
So we'll get to how to
solve that problem today.
So this lecture
comes in two halves.
Contract theory and mechanism
design is all of it.
The first half is
going to feature
an application in-- back to
our favorite stomping ground--
the medieval village economy.
And then as I've
already anticipated,
the second half
is going to focus
on generalizing the concepts and
talking about smart contracts
and validation and trust.
So if you looked at this map,
in this case, it's not England,
it's France, you would see
these solid filled in circles,
the little Cheerios,
and the empty circles,
and small dependent settlements.
So these stand for villas with
only demesne, so to speak,
which means everyone
worked for the lord
and didn't own their own land.
There are mixed villages
that have demesne,
but the households own some
of their own land as well.
And then villages
where the lord--
like the Bishop of
Winchester in England
doesn't own any of
the land at all.
And these are just
scattered little hamlets.
So you can start to
spot some patterns here.
This is kind of
the chief of state
of the lord, the
lord of this area;
these little Cheerios
surrounding it or halfway
filled in with some land
directly farmed for the lord;
and then a little
further out you
get these open circles where
the lord does not directly
have a claim on the land,
although there may be taxes
due.
So that's summarized
in this first slide
under alternative
forms of organization.
When it's held in demesne only,
then essentially the peasant
population are entirely slaves.
And others there was
no land like that.
Instead, there were
not labor obligations,
but households were obliged
to pay rent to the lord
a certain amount of
grain that was due.
And we'll come back to
what that contract might
have looked like.
And those empty, open
circles were really far away
from the central monastery.
So we got three different
kinds of organization here.
And theory that we're about
to write down is going to say,
well, maybe these
forms of organization
varied from one
village to the next,
depending on how close
they were to the manor,
in particular because
there's private information.
And if you're very
close up, then
essentially the lord
sees everything.
And if you're very
far away, it's
extremely costly and difficult
for the lord to see everything.
And so those exchanges
have to be incentive,
compatible, and
induced, concepts
we're going to define today.
Or you may see nothing except
with a cost where there's
an audit, like a tax authority
going in to actually take
a close look, but at some cost.
So here's the model
for simplicity.
Just imagine there
are two agents,
only one lord named
agent 2 and one agent
named agent 1 that's a
stand-in for the entire villa
population.
So agent 1 here is seeing
his or her endowment,
1 stands for the
household number,
epsilon for the fact
that the endowments are
the yields of crops grown on
the land farmed by agent 1
and a random.
And furthermore,
at least initially,
only seen by agent 1, the villa.
We can simplify.
This notation was
here deliberately
to try to remind
you a bit of things
that we've done earlier
in other lectures
where epsilon was a shock.
We talked about portfolios of
land as a function of shocks,
and so on.
But in fact, this whole
object can be just summarized
by theta, a value
lying in some sum
set capital theta, occurring
with realizations p of theta.
Agent 2, the lord,
we're going to simplify.
The endowment is public, there's
no private information there.
Agent 2 is, again,
the central monastery.
Both these endowments,
the e1 of epsilon,
or theta on the one
hand and W on the other,
can be more than one crop.
It can be multiple crops.
So K is the dimension
of the vector.
So what do these guys do?
The two agents agree to a plan,
a resource allocation rule,
which allows agent 1, the guy
with the private information,
to be sending
messages to agent 2,
and as a result of the message,
some tax is paid from agent 1
to agent 2.
So little m is a
particular message,
big M here is the set
of all possible messages
or the message space.
This is quite an
abstract concept.
It could be something like,
it rained today, or, how's
the weather over there,
or, I lost my plow.
This abstract message space.
But we're going to
give it some meaning.
The meaning happens through
this allocation rule.
Namely, if theta is
the true endowment
of agent 1, how
much of the tax, f,
is a function of
what is said, M.
And they all agree to this
abstract message space
and to this allocation rule f.
So agent 1 can map what he
says into his overall outcome.
So let's suppose the
agent 1 knows exactly
what he or she wants to do.
Namely, when his or
her endowment is theta.
The best possible
message that could
be sent in that abstract
space is, we'll put a star on,
an m star of theta.
This is the maximizing message
sent by agent 1 to agent 2
when his endowment
is actually theta.
This is way to write the
fact that it's maximizing.
Namely, the overall outcome for
agent 1 in terms of agent 1's
utility is as high
as it can possibly
be relative to any other
possible message that
could be sent.
There may be ties, but at
least m star is maximal.
The inequality doesn't
go the other way.
If it went the other way,
less than or equal to,
there would be a message
m that did better
than what we said
is the maximum,
and that would be
a contradiction.
So 83 is just a statement
of maximization.
Now, this holds for any other
possible message, little m.
And in particular,
if the reality
had been something else, say
theta tilde and not theta,
m star would still denote
the maximizing message,
but it would maximize
that theta tilde.
The role that it
plays here is that is
a particular message like m,
a particular counterfactual
message.
But because it's
a valid message,
although it would have been
sent in different circumstances,
we just can substitute
m star of theta
tilde up on the right-hand
side as a particular m since 83
holds for all
possible m, and that
gives us this expression 84.
So the way to read this is that
when the agent's true endowment
is theta, see theta
on both sides,
and m star theta is maximal,
that weakly dominates,
saying what that actual
dominates what the agent would
have said in the
counterfactual situation, where
though his endowment
were theta he could have
said m star of theta tilde.
With me so far?
So these are just
simple statements
of maximization and notation.
Now we're going to make
a bigger move here,
although it seems
rather innocuous.
We're going to change
the message space
and we're going to change
the allocation rule.
The way we're going to
specialize the message space
is to require that the agent
announce values of theta.
They're still not seen
by the monastery agent 2,
but the message space is my
output was high this year,
my output was low, et cetera,
for as many possible values
of endowment as there might be.
So we change the message space.
The next thing we do is
change to transfer rule.
Well, for one thing, we have
to define the transfer rule
over messages about theta.
So we denote that g of theta.
But actually, we're not
going to, quote unquote,
"change the rule."
We're going to define g
to be the same function f,
but f used to operate
on abstract messages
whereas g operates on messages
about the actual endowment.
So the right-hand side here
is a composite function.
You have theta tilde, you send
message m star of theta tilde,
f acts on that.
So it's a composition
of f and m,
whereas g operates directly
on messages about output.
There is another
way to see this,
which is where we're going
in terms of the result.
The agent knows the
maximizing action
for every possible theta.
So he could program
the computer to do
what he wants it to do in
terms of sending a message up
to whatever key gets pushed.
So effectively,
he starts pushing
keys that denote the theta,
in this case, theta tilde,
instead of actually
sending a message.
The computer sends the message
on behalf of the agent.
Of course, the agent has,
a 1, has coded it all up.
So the computer
functions properly
on behalf of the
agent's best interests.
All right.
So now we've changed two
things, the message space
and the allocation rule.
And now we go back to
previously derived equation, 84,
that said this thing,
but start substituting--
m star of theta
tilde is composed
with f will be g of theta
tilde on the left-hand side,
f composed with m star of
theta will be g of theta
just by the definition of g.
So we get this.
We get 85.
That's just substitution.
But it's powerful.
OK?
So now we can start
calling it, misleadingly,
a truth-telling constraint.
Now, no one is choking
this guy to death.
He gets to say
whatever he wants.
But under this new message space
with the g allocation rule,
when theta actually
happens, he wants
to say it did, as opposed
to when theta actually
happens, lying and saying
that it's theta tilde.
So this constraint 85, which
was actually derived just
from a principle
of maximization,
actually starts looking like a
truth-telling constraint, where
the space of messages is the
space of possible outputs,
and now miraculously,
the agent's
going to tell the monastery
the truth about it.
The bill is going to tell the
monastery the truth about it.
But we're not kind of
insisting on truth telling.
85 is derived as
a first principle.
They're called incentive
compatibility constraints.
Anyway, so once
this mechanism is
in place, whenever
theta happens,
the agent will say
so, affecting g.
The g is actually what
would have happened
under the old mechanism
when theta happens
and the agent announced m star
of theta in the abstract space.
So this is now achieving exactly
the same set of allocations.
In fact, we could call them
shock contingent allocations.
If you go back to the
very early notation
with the shock in
there, it looks
like the agent is announcing
what those shocks are,
and under this
allocation rule, will
be telling the truth
about them as long as 85
is part of the system.
So just like before when
we had states of the world,
we talked about state contingent
allocations, like gift giving,
the risk sharing rules, and
so on, here, again, we're
enumerating these states,
epsilon in this case,
when we talk about state
contingent allocations.
So the method is
exactly the same
as before as long as we
append onto the system
constraints like 85.
Another way to say that
is all of the consequences
of private information
are captured by 85.
So we can go and do our thing
with the programming problems,
maximizing lambda
weighted sums of utilities
subject to resource
constraints, and so on, and just
append on these extra so-called
truth-telling constraints.
So we don't have to search
over abstract message spaces,
because what's
the limit of that?
Anybody can come up
with a message space.
It's too abstract and
not very specific.
We restrict the message space,
but without loss of generality.
And anything we could have
done in an abstract way
with m and f, we can
now do with theta and g.
So here, in fact, would
be a programming problem.
We're going to maximize
the lambda-weighted sums
of utilities.
A little bit of new
notation, I guess,
if I forgot to say it earlier.
Theta occurs with
probability P of theta.
So summing over theta makes
this an expected utility
representation on
the left-hand side.
Note that what the
agent gives up,
minus g, is what the
monastery gets, plus g.
There is an expected utility
term for the monastery, too.
This is a two-party contract.
They're going to
maximize this thing.
We are going to maximize
it for them to determine
Pareto-optimal allocations and
make a prediction about what
they would be doing, subject
to this extra constraint--
87, the so-called
truth-telling constraint.
You may say, well, where
is the resource constraint?
Well, it kind of got substituted
in to the objective function
because what agent 1 gives
up is what agent 2 gets.
So there's no reason to talk
about consumption of agent 1
and consumption of
agent 2, and make sure
that it adds up to the total.
That's just a handy
convenience in this setup.
So more ways to implement it--
the villa is, at the
end of the year--
and so far, this is
a static problem--
the agent just hands over
goods to the monastery.
Could be a lot, could
be a little-- whatever
it is, it's totally accepted.
As a solution to this
problem, instead of saying,
oh, I'm announcing theta and I'm
going to give you g of theta,
they just hand it over.
It's the same thing.
It's just simpler.
Now the key is, again,
this incentive constraint,
which makes sure that
agent 1 has the incentive
to hand over the right
amount, the right amount being
the solution to this
programming problem.
Second consequence-- suppose
there's only one good, wheat.
When you look at 87, it's
going to simplify to something
trivial, namely, no trade.
Why is that?
This says utility
on the left weakly
exceeds utility on the right.
And g of theta on the left
must be less than or equal to g
of theta tilde on the right
because it's the same function
u.
And theta is the same
argument otherwise.
But you can reverse the
logic, and put theta tilde
for the actual
situation and theta
for the counterfactual
situation.
You'll get another
inequality because this holds
for all theta and theta tilde.
And then you're going
to have the consequence
that g of theta tilde on
the left must be less than
or equal to g of
theta on the right.
Now we've got two inequalities--
less than or equal to,
greater than or equal to.
It must be equal to.
So g is the same
regardless of theta.
So at most, the
villa is paying over
to the monastery a constant tax.
But then it's not
state contingent,
and it could be 0 if we wanted
to make them both better off.
So that degeneration
does not necessarily
happen if there's
more than one good.
And it could be another good
is like labor, not just wheat.
And the specification
is, you've got to go,
here's the transfer of wheat.
And otherwise, I'm
going to go work for you
on the land in my
village, or trundle off
to the monastery to work there.
So there could be a
wheat/labor trade-off,
as an example of
more than one good.
And then this is not trivial.
And some trade is possible.
Another special
case-- if agent 1
is risk averse in a
certain way, then we
may be able to get some trade
even if there's only one good.
So this is just going to
exploit the possibility
that if agent 1 has a strictly
concave utility function,
then the degree of it will
determine his or her adversity
to lotteries.
So for example, you
might say I'm high today.
I would pay a big
tax, but I'm going
to pretend that I'm low so
that I pay less of a tax.
But that claim of
having a low value
may make the tax very random.
And if he's really high,
and that being a high value
makes the guy very risk
averse for odd reasons,
then he may not
want to claim low
because he prefers to avoid
the randomness associated
with the lotteries.
So lotteries in
general are going
to help sustain trade
because they exploit
differentiable risk aversion.
So with that said, we can now
write this program up here
in lotteries.
Let's call pi of tau given
theta the probability
of a transfer from agent 1
to agent 2 of magnitude tau,
conditioned on the
agent saying theta.
And then this program
6 over here becomes 7,
where we're still maximizing
a weighted sum of utilities
subject to an implicit
resource constraint.
What one guy gives
up, the other guy
gets, in the tau, but also
this now-revised incentive
constraint.
And let me read it for you--
when theta comes up,
that's the actual yield.
Agent 1 says, Yep,
that's my theta.
That's the message,
tells the truth about it.
That implements a lottery
with probabilities pi of tau
so that summing over all the
tau gives the expected utility
of the agent for having theta
and telling the truth about it.
And on the right-hand
side is the counterfactual
that although theta came
up, he lies, and says,
nope, I'm theta tilde.
But that comes with this
potential randomness,
and the expected utility
on the right-hand side
is not greater than
it is on the left.
So that's the same kind of truth
telling incentive compatibility
constraint as before, with
the simple addition that we
have those lotteries in there.
You will recognize, because
we've done this before,
that with the lotteries, things
turn into linear programs.
So when you look at this,
the control variables
are these pi of taus, and
in the objective function,
they're multiplied by
these leading coefficients.
And in the constraint
set, the control variables
are, again, the pi
of taus weighted
by certain coefficients.
So I won't repeat what we
talked about that day when
we introduced this concept.
I'm really just
trying to remind you
that we've already
seen things like this,
except that here, we
have added the addition
of these so-called truth-telling
or incentive compatibility
constraints, also written
down in lotteries.
And because it's a linear
programming problem,
we can compute solutions
to it, which you've
been doing on some of
your homework problems,
not with lotteries
per se, but computing.
Now, there is another twist
here in terms of incentives.
If it's true, say, that
high-theta guys might
want to claim to be low because
they would pay less of a tax,
I should say, where is
that intuition coming from?
If agent 1 is risk averse
and agent 2 is risk neutral,
then agent 2 should bear
all the risk, in which case
when agent 1 has a
high value of theta,
he would transfer stuff to 2.
And likewise, if agent 1
has a low value of theta,
he would receive stuff
from 2, and consumption
would be constant if it
weren't for these incentive
constraints.
But agent 2 doesn't
have to be risk neutral.
They could both be
strictly concave people.
We still know that
apart from 94,
there is this monotonicity
condition, that consumptions
should co-move together.
So when theta is high, agent
1's consumption could go up.
But so also should
agent 2, meaning
that some of that high value is
being transferred to agent 2.
So it's the same whether or
not 2 is risk neutral or not.
Now, that intuition when
the endowment is high,
agent 1 could claim
that it is low in order
to avoid paying this transfer.
But there is a way to
preventing him from doing that.
It's like-- I don't know,
I'm not a gambler myself--
like when they call you,
they put it on the table,
and say, let me see your hand.
So they say, OK, you're
claiming you're low.
Actually, let me apologize--
this goes the other way.
You only need to worry about
high guys claiming to be low.
Low guys cannot
claim to be high.
Why?
Because if they claim to be high
without necessarily taking it
away, they have to
display their wealth.
And then it would be
clear, if they can't do it,
that they were lying.
So we kind of have a one-way
incentive constraint going on
here.
That's not terribly important,
but the show and tell
is a device that can be used.
And we'll come back to it later.
All right, so now let's
get into multiple periods,
be a little bit more realistic
about this, just slightly--
two periods rather than one.
Same actors-- agent 1 having
these random endowments
in both periods, agent 2
having a potential time-varying
endowment W. And then these
probabilities of shocks,
theta 2 to agent 1
in the second period,
are basically potentially
non-independent they
could be determined by the shock
that agent 1 incurs at date 1.
So if you're into
statistics, you
could call this a Markov
process and be fancy about it,
but all you really
need to know is
the state-dependent notation.
OK, so I want to know what's
an optimal arrangement
in this world.
So we write down the
maximization problem,
which is the lambda-weighted
sum of expected utilities,
obviously taking into
account both periods
subject to resource constraints
and to incentive compatibility
constraints.
So there's a lot of lines
here, unfortunately,
but it's not so bad.
This is lambda 1
weight for agent 1,
lambda 2 weight for agent 2.
Otherwise, this is the first
period expected utility
when the agent is
theta 1 and says so,
affecting the transfer tau.
This new term here is
beta, discount rate,
times the expected
utility in period 2.
Period 2, agent 1 has theta 2--
actually says so.
And then you integrate up
over all possible thetas
and discount it by beta.
One little subtlety
I'm about to feature
is the transfers at day
2 can depend not only
on what is said about
theta 2, but what
was said about theta 1--
the history, as it
were-- in date 1.
Date 1 is the first day.
Nothing's happened.
There's no history,
but there is a history
to potentially use at day 2.
So this is the
objective function.
And again, the
resource constraints
are loaded in here because
what agent 1 gives up,
agent 2 is getting.
So we don't need to worry
about that, for both dates
and whatever the
outcome of the lottery.
Now, let's think about
the incentive constraints,
working backwards, as
in dynamic programming,
from the last period.
So say some theta 1 were already
announced, and that's history.
They arrive at day 2.
Agent 2 has a choice about
saying the actual value
of theta, theta sub 2, telling
the truth, or lying about it,
and saying theta 2 tilde.
So what does that incentive
constraint look like?
We're already in the last date,
so there's one period left.
It's period 2.
And this is got theta 2,
say so, versus got theta 2
and lie about it,
saying theta tilde.
This history, theta 1, is
the past in the archives.
So it's in both sides because
that's already public record--
not what theta 1 was per se,
but that it was announced,
theta tilde.
Now the incentive
constrain at day 1,
working backwards from day
2, looks a little bit more
complicated.
But it's just going to use
what we already know from 96--
that they will tell the
truth in the second date,
regardless of
whatever history was
announced in the first date.
So these branches
here, with the beta
in front of it on both sides,
are here, have theta 2,
say theta 2 truthfully, versus
have theta 2, and say theta 2
truthfully.
So on both the left and
the right-hand side,
the second period
is not in doubt.
The agent is going to be
telling the truth because of 96.
The real action has to
do with the first term
of the first date,
namely have theta 1
and say so versus have
theta 1 and lie about it,
and say theta 1 tilde.
And this inequality
constraint means
that a weakly dominant
strategy is to tell the truth--
have theta 1, say so.
Now note, again,
the interesting way
in which this history evolves.
If they say theta 1, it will be
part of the history of day 2.
They could say-- they won't--
but they could have said theta
1 tilde and lied about it.
And that would also be recorded
on the books as history.
So the thing that's
varying at the second date
is this announcement
in the first date,
as we consider logically
what the agent will
want to say in the first date.
So this is another
incentive constraint.
And again, there's
more than one of them.
This is for every
possible actual theta 1.
In any potential counterfactual
announcement theta 1 tilde,
constraint like this holds.
So I should have caught
myself earlier on this,
because I talked
about the incentive
constraint or the
truth-telling constraint
as if there were only one.
But in practice, there
are many because we
have many possible
realizations of theta.
So what we've done today so
far is called the "revelation
principle," meaning that those
truth-telling constraints can
be imposed without
any loss of generality
in the search for private
information-constrained
optimum.
Now, there's an issue
of language here.
Instead of talking about a
Pareto-optimal allocation,
we should be talking about an
information-constrained optimal
allocation.
Some people-- I don't love it--
talk about Pareto optimality
as first best, and this notion
of constrained optimality
as second best, with the good
intention of distinguishing
those two cases.
It's second best
but unavoidable,
because you cannot get around
these kinds of incentive
constraints.
They may or may not be
binding, but you definitely
should be writing them down.
And when they're binding,
they constrain the solution,
and hence the terminology
"constrained optimum."
Question so far?
So what do we know
about the solution?
One thing I've
already hinted at--
if there were full information,
then if we go back,
this is a version of
what you've seen before.
It's written out as two periods.
But remember, the way we solve
these things in Debreu decision
tree, we said for any date
and for any history of states
leading up to that, we'll have
a risk-sharing rule, a transfer
rule, which is a function
only of the current aggregate
endowment and nothing else.
So the full risk-sharing problem
without the truth-telling
constraints will devolve into
a series of static problems,
which means the
transfer rule at day 1
would be the same as the
transfer rule at day 2.
But in fact, when we have
this information-constrained
efficient arrangement,
it's almost surely the case
that we're not going to be
able to get to the full risk
sharing.
And likewise, if you're
already at the second date,
you're kind of
doomed, especially
with one good, no lotteries.
You can't have a theta
2-contingent transfer
at the second date.
But possibilities remain
at the first date.
Why?
Precisely because you can
tie the allocation rule
in this lottery
at the second date
to what is announced
at the first date.
So this history of
messages starts to matter.
Or another way to
put that, when it's
necessary to have that, what
happens at the second date
is no longer a static problem.
You have to utilize
what also happened
at the first date, which you
could call a tie-in of sorts--
intertemporal cross-period
ties in of the second date
to the first date.
It also reminded me of what the
historians are talking about.
They said, oh, these manners
are terribly inefficient,
bound by tradition.
They can't break
away from the past.
Well, the theory
we're going over
says that there's a very
good reason why they would
like to be bound by the past--
for incentive purposes.
So one example of that
is borrowing and lending.
I mean, suppose the
villa has a low output,
and they say, look, I promise--
let me pay less or
borrow, and I'll
repay the loan next period.
And there's a commitment
device to make sure
that the loan will be repaid.
So would the villa want to
claim to be a lender when
the income is low?
No, they would want
to be a borrower.
And conversely, when
the income is high,
they're going to want to be
a lender, as long as they're
guaranteed of
getting stuff back.
So what's going on here?
You're tying what happens
at the second period
to what happens at
the first period--
those so-called
intertemporal connections.
It's not like you say
a theta, and then you
pay high or low today.
You say a theta, you may
pay high or low today,
but there are
consequences for tomorrow.
So you choose what
you're saying to give you
the maximum possible utility.
And you have an incentive
to smooth consumption.
So when you're low,
you want to say so.
Why?
Because that's better for you
in terms of getting money today,
where you value it more
than tomorrow, where
you're likely to be higher.
That was a bit of a digression.
It also comes up at the
bottom of the slide.
So the borrowing
and lending scheme
is an example of the past
mattering in a very trivial way
with the borrowing and lending.
What you've got to pay
today is a function
of whether you were a
borrower or lender last time.
It's not time consistent.
By the time you roll
around to day 2,
and ask these guys whether
they would like to start over,
they're, like, yeah, sure,
we can both be better off.
The incentive
constraint is imposed
to get them to behave properly,
as best they can, at date 1.
Once date 1 has happened
and we move to date 2,
there is no longer a
need for that constraint.
And if we were to resolve
the problem at day 2,
they would likely do
something different.
So it's called
"time inconsistent."
The arrangement is not going
to be consistently carried out
over time, voluntarily.
They're going to be
bound by these rules.
So then the thing at the
bottom of the slide, claim 1--
borrowing and lending
is not optimal.
So let's go back to this.
Say the solution
to this program 8
is the borrowing and
lending solution.
When theta is low, one borrows.
When theta 1 is high, the
agent lends, and re-pays back,
with the payment going
in the reverse direction
in the second period.
I claim that's not optimal.
It's probably still mysterious.
When the agent is
low, he strictly
prefers to say he's low rather
than saying that he's high.
That makes this inequality
constraint strict.
Likewise, when
the agent is high,
he strictly prefers
to say he's high
rather than saying he's low.
That makes this
inequality strict.
Well, if both
inequalities are strict,
neither one can be binding.
We might as well solve
the programming problem
as if they weren't there
in the first place.
Because now we know
they're not binding.
And what happens if
you solve this problem
without the constraints?
That's the full
risk-sharing problem.
And it can't be optimal because
they'll lie their head off
about their income because
there's no consequences.
So that's the way to
think through the bottom
of this slide.
Full insurance isn't
feasible, not implementable
because it's going to violate
the incentive constraints.
And borrowing and lending
is not optimal, either.
Which means, well,
what is optimal?
What is the actual
solution to that program?
Well, actually,
it's a hybrid scheme
that is a bit like risk-sharing,
and borrowing, and lending.
When you're low,
you say you're low.
You borrow, but you actually
get even more money,
but less money
than you would have
if it had been
full risk sharing,
and vice versa for
when you're high.
So it's a hybrid contract
that is mixing up
the two aspects,
which makes sense
because neither extreme
is a good thing.
So you end up in the middle.
So this slide is
about the other option
I alluded to at the beginning.
Let's revert back
to a static problem.
There's a cost K,
use of resources,
which the agent
2, the monastery,
can incur in order to go
and take a look at agent 1's
actual outputs.
So instead of claims about
it, which will also happen,
there's kind of like this
possibility of an audit.
It's as if in the US, you
file your income tax returns
making claims about stuff,
but with a certain probability
the IRS will audit you, and find
out the truth of the matter.
And if you're caught
lying, you go to jail.
That's how they got
Al Capone, actually--
not for all the
crimes, but because he
misreported his income.
So K is this audit cost.
And we can introduce
another variable
called d, where d is the dummy.
d equal 1 for audit or d
equals 0 for not audit.
And then we could enhance our
transfers or the lotteries
of transfers to depend
on whether or not
there's an audit--
equal 1 for an audit,
equals 0 for not.
When there's no audit,
they have to rely
on the filing of the return
or the message that was sent.
When there is an audit, they
get to compare the message that
was sent with the actual theta.
And as you could
imagine, going-- you
could kill the guy, going
to jail or whatever.
So I'll spare you this slide
except that the incentive
constraint will now take
advantage of the fact
that lying is a pretty
treacherous thing.
Because with a certain
positive probability,
you'll get caught in the
lie, and you can make
the guy's utility really low.
Later after class, you can look
at this inequality constraint.
It's this line here that you
can make a very low number.
Because you would penalize
the guy if he said
he was theta tilde, and he was
actually revealed to be theta.
And this is on the
right-hand side
of the incentive constraint.
So the lower you can
make this number,
the easier it is to satisfy
the incentive constraint,
and the more you're
going to move back
toward the full
information solution.
But it comes at a
cost, because this K
is a cost, a real cost, that
has to get subtracted off
from resources.
So when that cost K
is very, very high,
you will not be
auditing very much.
The audit will be random.
And only rarely
will you actually
carry it out in order to
conserve on resources.
So at the beginning, I
mentioned the institutional
configuration.
Is it true that those outlying
villas doing their own farming
were audited or audited less
rarely than the ones close
to the monastery?
And this theory we
just went through
allows one to think
about those as maybe what
happened in practice, consistent
with the institutional data.
So I want to turn to the second
part of the lecture, which
has to do with mechanism design
that we just did, but splice
that into smart contracts.
The shorthand for this
is, think about a contract
as a smart contract implemented
with today's modern technology.
We just talked about
mechanism design
as delivering contracts
between a villa and a monastery
as an example.
And along the way, we'll
talk about encryption,
and hashes, and
database management,
and these protocols.
Encryption-- we've talked
about distributed ledgers.
Encryption's like
the third part of it.
We talked about ledgers
as transferring value,
as in m-Pesa or
other situations.
We talked about ledgers as
contracts to reconcile trades.
This third thing
is keeping secrets
through encryption, which
is logical to have here
because we just got done talking
about private information.
Is it new?
No, not at all.
Encryption is ancient, literally
thousands of years old.
If you go back to
Mesopotamia, they
would be shipping goods around.
They had created little
tokens which they
put in clay sealed envelopes.
If the seal was broken, you'd
know there was some tampering.
And otherwise, when
the goods arrived,
the receiver of the
goods can reconcile
the goods in the shipment
with this invoice,
after breaking the seal.
So those are clay
in Mesopotamia,
and that's where Mesopotamian
writing came from,
actually, is from these tokens.
Or in medieval
England, they had what
they called "tally sticks,"
which were just wood,
willow sticks.
The borrower and the lender
would make an agreement.
The borrower would
promise to repay.
They would write these
things on wooden ledgers
and split it in half.
And so the investor lender
would have half of the stick
and carry it around,
could present it
to the borrower for
payment, but could also
sell it to third parties.
And so those willow sticks
circulated around like money
as a means of payment.
The point of the willow--
it had unique grain,
so you could match the
stalk with the check.
And if it didn't match, you know
that the person presenting it
is trying to commit some fraud.
So it's another early
example of encryption.
Encryption today, intuitively--
this isn't quite right--
can be thought of factoring.
So as you may know if you're
MIT students trained in Computer
Science, and Algebra,
and so on, when
you multiply two prime
numbers together,
you get another number--
3 times 7, then 21, and
you know how to factor it.
But when those primes get
big and are multiplied,
it's virtually
impossible to know
what are the two numbers that
were being multiplied together.
So the output looks like
an encrypted message.
You can try to solve
it, but you have
to try all possible
combinations.
And it gets to be
really hard to do that.
Another way you can
use factors, though,
is to give someone
part of the solution.
Like here's the product
encrypted, multiplied together,
but I actually know the answer.
I'll give you one
of the factors.
You can easily figure
out the other factors.
And so that's like hashes.
The hash itself means nothing,
but it is evidence of something
if someone comes along and
gives you one of both factors.
Because then you can
rehash the message
and verify that the underlying
message was the one that
generated the hash.
And finally, we come to
cryptographic puzzles,
which means the factors
are big, but not too big.
So then, you could
imagine spinning
the wheels of the
combination of a safe
to try to figure out which two
factors generated the number.
It's solvable,
but it takes time.
That's what Bitcoin uses--
these cryptographic
puzzles, among other things.
So the three objects,
three types of things,
are encryption,
which is done now
with private and public keys.
And I'm happy to tell
you more about that.
I even have a primer that
I wrote with Nicholas, a CS
student here at MIT.
Took me quite a
while as an economist
to understand this stuff.
You probably heard, though,
about public and private keys.
The public key is
used for encryption.
The private key is used
to decrypt the message.
Hashing I've mentioned already,
like multiplying factors
together.
Cryptographic puzzles, I
guess I mentioned again--
the thing is to
solve the puzzle,
you don't spin the
wheels of the safe.
You actually run a computer.
And that's where Bitcoin is
chewing up all the electricity,
as all these many
miners are trying
to find solutions to
find the actual factors.
So Bitcoin uses all three.
It's actually pretty amazing
and pretty complicated.
It's using signature schemes,
cryptographic puzzles,
and something else I haven't
talked about-- hashes
with Merkle trees.
But the entire history of the
transactions on the ledger
is hashed together
with an identifier,
allowing what's called Merkle
trees as an economic way
of storing all that data.
Bitcoin uses proof of work.
As I said, you need the
equipment and the electricity
to try to solve the
cryptographic puzzle.
The premise here is
that it's kind of random
who solves the puzzle.
And the premise is most
of the miners are honest.
We'll come back to
that momentarily.
So since the larger
number are honest,
and the person that solves the
puzzle is chosen at random,
the guy solving the puzzle
is likely to be honest.
Hence, they validate
the message.
Another two objects here--
homomorphic encryption
allows computation
on top of cipher text
for individual agents.
And multiparty
computation is a version
of that that applies
to multiple agents.
It's easier to show you a
little bit of the notation.
So m is the message.
Oh, yeah, M like message,
like we just did.
But the message is
supposed to be private.
On the right-hand side, you
have this allocation rule
or function, f, that
seems to require
the actual message, which means
the message, if it's going
to a third party, is
revealed, whether it's
Safaricom or something else.
But on the left-hand
side, there's
another way to do this, which
is as amazing as it is simple.
You take the message
m, and you encrypt it.
Then you take the function
f, which doesn't know what
it's doing--
it's operating on the
encrypted message.
And if you decrypt the
whole thing at the outcome,
at the end of the day,
you get the right answer.
You get the stuff on
the right-hand side.
The encrypted space
looks like junk.
It's just all a bunch of
bits, zeros, and ones,
with hashes, and dollar signs,
or whatever you want there.
No one could possibly read it.
That's what state of the
art encryption is all about.
So you take one thing
and do something else.
You can add them together.
You can do rank ordering.
It's like junk compared to junk.
But it turns out that
all those operations
have meaning when done
on the encrypted space.
So homomorphic means isomorphic.
Those underlying true message
spaces and the encrypted spaces
are equivalent to each other.
It's on to
one-to-one, and so on.
Multi-party computation
is very similar,
except there are
multiple agents.
So this means that
what you want to do
is take inputs from
the different agents,
like their wealth.
They want to see who
is the richest guy.
And they apply a function f,
which is like a rank ordering,
and get an outcome.
But these guys don't want
to reveal their wealth.
They just want to know
who is the richest guy.
So another way to do this
is take the afferent inputs
from the agents, and encrypt it.
Now nobody knows
anything about what
the other people are saying.
You apply f to those
encrypted messages--
fine-- in the encrypted space.
No harm done.
And then you decipher
the whole thing,
allowing, say, summaries
like a rank ordering,
without them ever knowing
what the amount of wealth
actually was, just who
is the wealthiest guy.
So that's called
multiparty computation.
Now, what's going on
with these algorithms?
We already talked
about proof of work.
Proof of work is Bitcoin.
They're using electricity
for the validation
among the miners.
Proof of stake is another one,
where the validation happens,
but instead of chewing up
electricity, they get to vote.
And their vote counts more
if they hold more coins.
Byzantine fault tolerance--
another algorithm--
this, one especially
the practical one,
is what I was
alluding to before.
If there are f failing
nodes that are either
faulty computers, or
malicious actors like hackers,
you just need 3 times f
plus 1 replicas in order
to be sure that you've
got a safe algorithm.
Because you can
compare across enough
of the entities who are safe
to be able to figure out who
was faulty.
Federated Byzantine
agents decide
not to rely on a third
party to do the validation.
They don't trust each other.
But they can name the
people they trust the most,
and you have overlapping
circles of trust.
And Stellar is a version
of that FBA protocol.
Now, what else about protocols?
Nakamoto was very clever
in giving Bitcoin miners
an incentive to mine properly
and not conceal outcomes,
to be running the
machines, and so on.
But it turns out it is
subject to some problems
like collusion.
So the economists have jumped in
and have become very critical,
although evidently, collusion
has never actually happened,
even though the number
of miners is very small.
Steve Morris, my colleague, and
Hyun Song Shin, now at the BIS,
looked at a classic problem
in computer science called
the Byzantine Generals problem.
And it has the property that
it's not incentive compatible.
Even though generals
have an incentive
to truthfully announce messages
and send them to each other,
it turns out if you put it in
the context of what we just
did--
a multi-agent mechanism
design problem--
they will not follow
the prescribed protocol.
It's not in their
self interest, when
they start doing
Bayesian analysis,
trying to figure out what
the other general knows.
So you can just impose
the algorithm and hope
people follow it.
But from what we did today,
that's a bit treacherous.
You really want to look at the
incentive of the validators
to follow the protocol.
And that's where we come
to mechanism design.
In fact, with
mechanism design, we
don't even need to worry about
agents telling the truth.
We don't need to monitor
or validate their messages.
The revelation
principle tells us
that agents will tell
the truth if we set up
the contract properly.
And not only that, we can
record past messages the way
we did in that
multi-agent problem.
Past messages just
get put on the ledger.
Because of the
signature schemes,
we can be sure that
they are valid,
they haven't been tampered
with over time, and so on.
So where we're going is to
implement the mechanism design
problem as a smart
contract with the code,
meaning like
dynamic programming,
you just map states into
outcomes with contingencies.
So you've already seen this
in the dynamic programs
that we've solved.
And you can separate out
that contracting part
from the ledgers.
We just have people agree to
the code, experiment with it,
make sure it works, set
up your encryption scheme.
And then it's like having an
auction without an auctioneer.
We're implementing that hybrid
borrowing/lending scheme
without having a third party.
It's just done by the
parties themselves.
And encryption, MPC and
homomorphic encryption,
make sure that all the
messages are private,
and nobody gets to
see those values.
And then at the
end of the day, you
can kick in the borrowing
and lending scheme
so that for example,
if it's a loan,
it's going to be repaid
because the loan is
backed by collateral.
So that would involve a
transfer on the ledgers.
So I'm not against the
distributed ledgers.
As I said, I just wrote
a whole book about it.
But I just want
to point out what
we did today, with the
privacy and the messages
and all of that, can be
done with encryption,
and allows smart contracts to
be executed on the ledgers.
All right.
Well, I went over
by a minute, and I
was rushing a bit at the end.
So take a look at these slides,
especially toward the end.
And see if you can map
this encryption back
into the earlier
part of the lecture.
That's really the main point.
And I will let you go.